when Drew met Linda I had to set up his
dates for him so I I had I planned out
like the Romantic uh like Drew was a his
nickname was the robot sound like a
total no Drew's nickname was the
robot and so he was always like and so
he wanted to do like a romantic even so
I created like a scavenger hunt a
romantic scavenger hunt with a website
and everything this is like Sero de
berser right list he one date that I
wanted to do was like uh like it was
creating like a digital scavenger hunt
and then going to go somewhere I didn't
know how to do it and he did it but uh I
didn't have spoon with Linda and all
those other romantic things we you help
with the proposal did you no I you did
the proposal oh look you did the
proposal you proposed yeah actually so
so she loves uh you know all the Places
You'll Go um you know the Dr Su so I
created we went for dinner at this place
we were filming in Toronto at the time
and uh for dessert you know she ordered
carrot cake but I had I had pre-made
this gigantic cake that had the
character on top holding the ring and
then I got down to propose and I had
this whole thing set up to make it
elaborate and I had camera set up and
mic set up but our camera guys had set
the cameras and checked the lighting and
then the the manager of the of the
restaurant wanted to get more Moody He
Turned the Lights way down low so in the
video I looked like it's just me and a
black booth next to me you don't even
see Linda and our our mic guy he miked
the other side of our table so all we
heard from the audio was the awkward
first date of the people next to us and
so none of it worked out but when I when
I went down to one knee and they brought
the cake over and uh also I had
pre-recorded the song uh Marry Me by
train I recorded it and then I had a
playlist of of music playing then that
song came on and I'm trying to get
Linda's attention to it and this whole
thing I set up and then at the end when
down it's Drew singing this song and
then and he's like like he she's like
what yeah she's like yeah yeah great
anyway so it's train so then I get down
on one knee and they bring out this cake
and all this thing I'm about to propose
and Linda looks at she's like uh no I
ordered carrot
cake and I'm like will you marry me
anyway yeah it was all me no if I had
planned it it would have been it would
have been
better shows how good you are on your
own yeah you're really good on your own
but that that's probably funny is that a
video that you have that well I have
it's a terrible video but and then Linda
did say after that she's like oh my God
like Linda's very You Know Her Like
She's just such a deep soul and loving
and she's like can we keep this to
ourselves for a few days she wanted to
just cherish it and I'm like yeah let's
keep it to ourselves for a bit we had
our crew Christmas party to go to after
that but I had flown in all her family
and friends so all of her best friends
and everybody were there so we went over
to this place for the crew Christmas
party and when she walked in the door
she said it felt like she had died
because you know all the people you know
in your life line up and they're there
as we're walking into this restaurant it
was literally all the people she knows
from her life and uh was it a Beautiful
Eulogy did they give a eulog yeah hey if
she said no I was just going to be a
really good sendoff party well you
waited what eight years yeah something
like you guys went out for eight years
before you asked yeah yeah wow zo Mur
for a long time oh yeah and she did
threaten my life so wait wait wait wait
so she threatened you like you were this
was did you get an ultimat i No I said
back that one up yeah I said to her I'm
like you know you know it'll happen when
it's going to happen but for me I love
the element of surprise and I love I was
like you're magician exactly and so I
could not do something predictable and
so there were several trips like we were
in Vancouver we actually went and
visited the place where my dad proposed
to my mom literally at Stanley Park
right on the edge and she thought it was
going to happen there and it didn't and
so then she was like I give up I'm not
going to think anymore about it were you
messing with her like when you were in
that spot did you go down to one 100%
cuz I didn't want her to she knew this
was the this was the spot you said this
is where my parents yeah and uh and so
you know there were little things here
and there where she's like we were in
another wait and you got down you got
down on your KN shoe or what what what
did you do
for the real
proposal no I just I went went there I'm
like how cute is this this is where Mom
Dad proposed to Mom and I'm like you
know we took a little selfie pict iOS to
you you take a ring off your finger and
you're like oh the one thing I will say
is I do have very clear audio and video
from my proposal I had a I had a drone I
had five cameras including hidden GoPros
and uh I have from your proposal
yeah at some point I'll tell you and she
didn't see it coming not a clue it was
there was drones and cameras all around
you can see on her face she had no idea
it was coming
really it'll all it'll all make sense in
the future stop Dad no I'm just trying
to set up a romantic kind of feel
Jonathan had gassy it was a gassy day
for Jonathan that wasn't gas was
supposed to be don't do Taco Bell before
you proposed
oh